what's up everybody and welcome
to outriders revealed today we
are going to
blow the lid off of square enix
and people can flies third
person shooter
and go in depth and talk about
everything that this game has to
offer I
go by the name of Malik Forte
and I am so grateful to be
joined today by people
can fly game director Bartek
Amita and lead writer Joshua
Rubin how's it going guys so
happy so happy Gaza could join
me today
you see ready to talk about this
game first off though I gotta
ask you guys
how's it feel to finally be able
to tell everybody about this
tell the world
about what you've been working
on it's amazing yeah this is our
first game
since we left Epic Games so it's
really a big moment for us so we
are super
excited that we can show all
about the game of the world yeah
it's crazy it has
been a while since we've seen a
game from people can fly you
guys are
primarily known for your
shooters so tell me what is it
that constitutes a
good shooter game in your
opinion in my opinion the good
shooter is made from
many elements like enemy
behavior level layout basic I
think the most important
part is when you press the
trigger and you feel this almost
tangible feel of
the gun this impact it has
that's what makes the great
shooter we've already
seen the first trailer that's
out and it's been revealed so we
kind of have a
little bit of an idea of the
story and what what to expect
without writer but
I'd like to know from your mouth
Bartek the director's pitch for
outriders so
sum it up for us sure it's want
a free player cob shooter we
have brutal powers
deep RPG mechanics and strong
story and while we're on the
subject of story it's
what we got you get Joshua
you've got quite some
credentials on you you are a
co-wrote Assassin's Creed 2 you
worked on destiny Game of
Thrones Walking Dead
with telltale games so you're
all about big story and big
characters how was it
bringing that here into this
game that's amazing I mean it's
amazing working on
great ip's but to get to invent
an IP to get to build a whole
new sci-fi world
from a blank canvas I mean you
know for creatives like us and
our team I mean
that's that's a dream job we you
know basically started from zero
we created
hundred years of lore you know
going back to like you know all
of the seismic
conflict that destroyed our
planet the colonization of the
new planet working
with these incredible scientists
to know how that would really
happen to how it
would then go disastrously wrong
because I mean you've seen the
trailer you've
played the game now you know
this is a dart game I mean and
that was really
important to us and building the
shooter that we wanted to build
a game that was
not clean sci-fi this is this is
a brutal nightmarish world that
you're
going into yeah you're not lying
about that and I've consumed
quite a bit of
sci-fi in my time from games to
movies and stuff this one takes
the cake as
being one of those darker
stories but you know what I feel
like right now
everyone else I want to get them
in the same frame of mind so
we're going to
show a little bit more here we
got a nice video for you guys to
check out
this right here is world
and story check it out
we came to Enoch looking for
hope a fresh start on an
untouched planet
then we found the singer so
we set out to discover it
that was our first
encounter with anomaly
when the storm struck the
outriders were forced back into
cryo sleep while we
slept the anomaly raged and the
creatures of enoch advanced
thirty years later when we
finally woke the world had
changed but so had we
with our advanced technology
rendered useless by the anomaly
a successful
colonization wasn't possible
and after all these years the
signal is still out there
and at its source a
chance to find answers
start again
okay all right so there was a
whole lot to digest there in
that trailer so let
me recollect a little bit wait a
second let me recollect so
humanity leaves
earth then the outriders go to
Enoch under the new planet Enoch
they're the
first to land there then they
discover a mysterious signal and
then everything
goes to hell am I right about
that Josh yeah yeah I mean
exactly you can sort of
imagine that you know this is
the last gasp of humanity earth
is gone and these
half a million refugees are on
this Ark ship to this lush green
new planet it's
a second chance for Humanity and
the outriders are like the
vanguard of this
crew they're the first ones to
land on the planet first boots
on the ground
they're the ones who are going
to be the mercenaries and
explorers that kind of
begin this colonization process
but then they get their first
taste of the
anomaly and yeah everything
goes to shit really
okay I'm it just doesn't know
more about the anomaly but first
I need to ask you
what's the signal because there
was a big you know point in that
trailer is a
big plot point so what is the
importance of the signal you
guys tell me this
think we can tell because
because one of the biggest
mystery of this planet no
slow but it's important is the
reason for a player to start a
journey okay so
it's the motive for the players
to figure out what that silly
noise and
what's the anomaly what is that
I can tell you this you first
see it as as you
did in the trailer as this storm
that kind of throws everything
we know about
physics upside down time gravity
when you you know if you get hit
by the storm
most people it just tears apart
but some people get rebuilt they
come back as
gods and this is what happens to
you - you're out right or when
you wake up
thirty years later the the you
discover that the flora and
fauna of this planet
has been hyper evolved these
little critters that were really
cute at the
beginning or not so cute anymore
and you your whole DNA has been
rebuilt and you
are now what they call Enoch
the altered Wow alright so the
anomaly is essentially what's
giving everyone their powers
right that's right
okay and I also saw in that
trailer there are a couple more
humans that look
like they're had some abilities
as well so some powers per se is
this safe to
call them altered as well are
they villains are they bad guys
like who are
they they are authors okay to
call them but not violence we
are trying to avoid
overall using villains and
heroes good guy and bad guys
overall we try to make
universe when everything is
quite grey yeah morally everyone
is morally
questionable from you to the
people you're fighting yes and
really the whole
world is trying the same without
those will be during our journey
some of them
will be maybe against you some
of them maybe will help you
right so it's not
really just that cut dry well if
you if it's good or bad
everything's kind of
just basically subjective toward
the player and that's pretty
cool alright so
I want to talk a little bit more
about what we saw in their
trailer as far as
the outriders that we saw is
that who I'm going to be playing
as you can but
you can also create your own and
Rider because we have that
customization
options so we can choose if you
want to be a female man if you
want to choose a
what kind of hair you want to
wear what kind of markings scars
so it's up to you
what you want to play I play
with a mohawk and big-ass beard
seems like I
would imagine that's kind of
like how you feel inside okay
yeah if I could
grow a mohawk again I promise so
let's go let's go that you you
don't
have to play us the outriders
you saw in that trailer I think
that's really
important for everyone know you
can create your own creation to
listen not
only that but we have these
incredible actors playing both
the male and female
versions of the main character
so you get really your own
unique version of
outriders when you play that's
really cool that's really cool
um so when you
create your outrider and you're
out there and you're playing
co-op with your
friends how does that work and
how does it work when you're
trying to tell a
story but you have three people
all playing in the same game
it's really
cool actually because we've got
about 90 minutes of cutscenes in
about two hours
of additional sidequest
cutscenes and it's epic
and in every one of those
cutscenes you your character
with all of your gear and
customization you are the star
of scene but your buddies are in
the scene
with you in the background was
their gear and gear gear and
customization and
what's really cool is that when
they see the same cutscene at
the same time as
you do they're the star of the
scene and you're in the
background is all your
gear in customization ok that's
cool that's cool is that
everybody gets to
represent or be represented in
their friends game as well as
their own and I
think that's cool you get to be
the star of your own game but
the support and
star and everyone else's at the
same time at the same time
that's really cool
I want to know a little bit more
about the story because I feel
like that
trailer gave us a good taste for
the grim and the dark
environment and
atmosphere that you're getting
ready to answer but where does
it go beyond it
does it get darker yeah I would
say it's kind of a classic
journey to the heart
of darkness it's got like a real
1970s Apocalypse Now vibe yeah
and you as you
go in search of the signal you
are leading this caravan through
this
war-torn wasteland and you go
all the way to the very edge of
civilization and
beyond there's a whole
world out there to
explore and it's filled with
history and mysteries that we
are only just
beginning to touch on in this
first game speaking of which is
there any more you
can tell us about Enoch because
I feel like we kind of got a
taste for how dark
it can be and how lush it can be
at the very same time is any
more
you can expound upon I really
think that they know he's one of
the protagonists
of this game yeah almost like a
character yeah oh really yes so
it has
so many mysteries and so many
secrets you will have to
discover and dig to
love that you know it goes from
like the mud and the grit of you
know what feels
like you know like like almost a
world war one on an alien planet
at the
beginning yes yeah but then
beyond that you go you go past
the edge and there
are forests and there are
mountains and there are deserts
and each of these
places is bigger than the last
and it's not an open world I
think that's
important to say
hmm but it's more of a like a
hub-and-spoke structure so you
go with your Caravan and when
you land in these
places that becomes your core
and then you move out from there
in every
direction getting to explore and
find more and more right very
cool very cool
I like that I like that because
it's not is you guys are using
these RPG elements
to tell this story and the
stories appears to be vast so I
can't wait to
jump in and it's just so
intriguing to hear what you guys
have to say about it
but while we're on the subject
of RPG elements I think it would
be cool right
now to dive a little bit deeper
into what those exactly are so
why don't we
go ahead and take a look at the
RPG elements and outriders
as we venture across
scenic we discover a
violent new world Bali slept
those that survived the anomaly
did what they could
to carve out a living and
something resembling society
took shape
we scavenge for weapons and
armor and trade what little
resources we have in
order to give ourselves a
fighting chance of survival
engineer vehicles
from scrapped and set out
towards the horizon and as we
pu farther into the
unknown
our powers grow
our knowledge of how to use them
but as we start to understand
our power we discover there are
others
who've paid a heavier price
oh man guys there's a whole lot
of fun happening in that right
there's so much
stuff to talk about but uh I
want to break down some of the
RPG elements that
I'm seeing here because it looks
like a lot man do you think
people are going to
be surprised with how robust the
RPG elements in outriders are I
think they
will be because on one hand we
double down on our expertise
with shooters but
then we add a lot of elements
that are more con with action
RPG games not with
the shooters okay so you say
common what are some other
traditional RPG elements
that you guys added into
outriders okay so I think never
again the most common
and traditional elements are the
side quests to the skill tree
the SS the of
course the loot the rarity of it
right now all of you like in the
RPG games we
have in our game great right and
lots of customization it looks
like as well - oh
yeah it can be customized right
well one thing I noticed you
guys were
customizing an out riders truck
in their trailer - well tell me
about that what
is this outriders truck and what
can I do with it I'll try the
truck is
basically your home yes so when
you're moving somewhere you're
taking your
truck with you and your friends
that we joined this track and
your journey but
the funny thing is when you join
your other colleague to play
multiplayer
multiplayer game then you create
the convoy of trucks support on
eBay
probably that you can't drive
the trucks by the way the trucks
are kind of your
home you'll have your own driver
so I have my own driver I don't
need to be
doing the drivers and what's
more you can add some trophies
to districts to
show off what you have done in
the game how is your progress
going so if you
kill a big-ass monster you can
put his head right on the front
of your truck
it's really cool too because
like then when you're with your
friends like and
you're this convoy when you come
and you create a hub at a place
that you land
you kind of create almost like a
circle like a wagon circle yeah
yeah you know
and like all your your buddies
are there and also your
characters are there your
NPC Corps convoy characters are
there and they can do things
like you know
upgrade your weapons and you
know you know fix repair things
and a new route
for you a lot of you can
decide quest for them
to more familiarize with them
you can chat yeah you can
actually sit around
the campfire and your story is
about old earth that's cool yeah
so a bit of a
safe space for you and your your
buddies right I'll talk a little
bit more about
hub areas because you have that
one with your cowboy but like
other towns and
cities where you can kind of
camp out - yeah there are these
settlements that
you come across where after the
failed colonization of Enoch the
survivors have
kind of gathered in these you
know crags and rifts that's of
safety from the
storms and the endless war and
kind of eke out this survival
civilization it
feels very gritty very real but
there's real lives going on
there and you can
get involved in these side
quests you know you can help
people with their
stories people are not so nice
that you find and there's
vendors right that have
these really unique items you
only get in these specific
locations so yeah and
each of these are a hub as well
that you could that you find
yourself in right I
noticed when I was planning
actually to I was in one of the
towns I think was
Rift City I believe I was hi
rift town rift town yeah I was
there and I went up
to the vendor and there was some
pretty nice gear there in his
shop that was
like almost I wanted to buy
about I didn't have enough scrap
to get it since
we're on the subject I want to
talk more about the gear in this
game because
there's like a ton of gear from
what I saw how many weapons are
in this game
hello there's so much so much
yeah there's incredible artists
cool-looking armor to the
beginning you
will start with the something
that we would have to scavenge
yeah the more we
progress the more booth are the
more crazy thinking as we become
yeah there's
this amazing sense of like the
first guns that you're using
really are like
you know like world war one
world war two really heavy
ballistic artillery
that feel like you've you know
built them younow out of just
crap that you
found right but as you go
further into this world and
deeper and deeper you get
these really otherworldly
weapons I mean there's this one
that I don't know my
favorite is like this one that's
like this molten lava gun that's
like
morphing in your hand as
you're blowing the shit
overall we wanted to reflect the
true items the world and story
around us so
we are smooth from the lasers
plastics and heavy yeah we're
keeping the
old-school here yeah but the
more the probably progress the
more crazy stuff
will begun right right well you
can modify these these things
too right the
gear goes in the color coding
with you when you're looting is
it similar to
like other we are using your ret
so you know the more rare items
the more
powerful it will be a color
coding is very similar because
we want to for the
elements is working good we
don't want to change them people
will be not lost
right begin new building game
right now there's a common
familiarity with that
between amongst gamers so in the
vein of customization and
enhancing my character
I wanna know a little bit more
about the skill trees that I saw
there could you
tell us little bit more about
that Bartek sure so when you
level up your
query points you can spend on
the skill tree and true skill
tree you're changing
how your character behaves on
the battlegrounds so you can
become more
powerful your skills can be more
important now than gums or maybe
you
like guns more than skills or
maybe you want to change your
speed or how you
behave in the cover so all of
this together natural hold the
gameplay we
define how your endgame build
works too so I can like increase
my health you can
increase or have your characters
of damage so it's all synergize
together so
you have to choose your own
perfect way through it and it's
cool it's worth it
to important that each class has
his own separate skill tree
right so basically
you can differentiate your
character and make it according
to your play style you
can just fine-tune it exactly
awesome dude that's awesome
that's awesome and I
imagine that works really good
with what we're getting ready to
talk about next
which is the classes and the
powers I guarantee you guys this
is the section
you've been waiting for we got a
little video to show you first
and then we're
gonna deep dive into
this stuff check it out
many threats stand between us
and the source of the signal
those of us who
survived exposure to the anomaly
move beyond our physical limits
we've become
altered as pyromancers we
manipulate explosive volcanic
energy and
devastating walls of flames as
tricksters you manipulate the
fabric
of time and space to
take out enemies by
as devastators we shatter the
earth a brute force powered by
the planet
itself
and so our journey
across Enoch begins
to discover what
lies at the heart
you
all right everybody this is the
part of the show I'm pretty sure
you've all been
waiting for we're getting ready
to break down these classes you
just saw the
Pyromancer the Devastator and
the trickster but to my
knowledge uh there's
this thing yes there's four
classes yes right now we'll
reveal only three of
them okay one will be secret
okay so how do these three
classes work trickster is
a sassy type time and space for
everyone who likes a lot of
movement around the
arena for people who like
to go behind the enemies
next one is Pyromancer a lot of
damage but you like array of
effects a lot of
fire that's Mario the last one
is Devastator guy for like
to fight on the short-range guys
who like to be tanky Buffy may
be little bit
reckless but that's for guys who
leave a person that's for me
I forgot like me who just like
to run straight into the action
without
consulting his team I'm totally
the guy who like I'm time and
space right like
I'm the trickster I like to like
alright see there's this really
cool thing you
can do I'm sorry I'm just gonna
take over where where you like
set your like
teleport exit right and then you
sneak up and you teleported
right behind all
of the fuckers and you do this
like temporal slice thing that
like freezes
their bodies and then they
become translucent you see their
skeletons like
dissolve inside and then just as
the big motherfuckers coming at
you you're out
of your exit point yes that's so
cool I don't want to talk about
this anymore I
want to see I don't know about
you guys but I'm ready to jump
to some some
gameplay yeah how's the sounds
of this alright let's do it
let's jump in
alright so paint the scene for
me where are we right here this
is the war zone
when you're out writer first
wakes up from cryo sleep engine
right into this
hellhole and you know
basically the idea is that
one of the aspects of the
anomaly is that it kills all
electronics more
complicated than a lightbulb so
humanity has been reduced to
sort of pre-world
War One technology so that's
that's what this feels like it's
like trenches and
tanks but on an alien planet the
enemy is you're fighting these
are the
insurgents who are you're the at
war with ya of course they don't
call
themselves that they call
themselves the X Isles and you
know understanding the
whole tragic story behind this
war is a big part of the mystery
that you're
solving right now we're looking
at the trickster am I correct in
saying that
yeah the trickster yeah so now
we see the temporal slice so
first ability you see that you
are slowing everyone and later
killing them
right now this is low trap so
that's really cool universe you
are fast but
you can even slow down faster
that's cool you know both the
bullets going in
slow motion inside that bubble
you're like totally neo body
parts we've lied I
noticed that your health was low
how did you hear though you're
receiving some
part of the health through your
assassination it's the whole
idea of
doing damage is what gives you
your health back and this right
here is the
Devastator correct yes does your
favorite class we are killing
them so
the more enemies around you the
better and the skill we're
seeing is the
earthquake so basically like a
better shot gun and so you can
synergize it
together and kill a lot of
enemies in the close close
combat oh the next kill
we see right now is the
basically armor it's a goner
that's changing into the
almost indestructible guy yeah
or you can even be more closer
and more tanky
and lower back that's
exactly what I need
can I be more tanky okay I like
it I like how his skin is like
rock solid his
or her depending on which way
you decide to go on
customization this is one of
the hub areas you were talking
about earlier if I'm not
mistaken is this uh
rift town rift on yes it's a
rift oh yeah this is one of the
first large hubs
in the game you come to you know
basically like after the anomaly
storms
have destroyed the first city
and the monsters have started
coming and the
insurgency have started rising
those who are loyal to the eca
have retreated into
this rift for protection this is
like one of the first places on
Enoch where a
kind of civilization has
survived right sort of I've
trying to it is a harsh
broken world yeah that you find
in this place but it's also the
first time in
the game that you really get to
slow down and start to kind of
explore and
start to kind of unravel some of
the mysteries that are a key
part of this
game yeah it feels desolate but
hopeful at the very same time so
how does the
loot system work I'm noticing
those vendors cannot buy and
sell things with
the vendors like gear or
whatever yes overall you are
finding a lot of stuff
in the world your hand scrub you
can destroy so you can receive
money for it
so we our money is called scrap
basically okay and then if you
have bad
luck let's say in the word
finding the cool load you can
buy it through the
vendors or maybe we're missing
some item that they want or
maybe there will be
some mod do you want to purchase
you can do this drill stop all
right all about
that scrap keeping a rocket how
do I move from one environment
and
get to the next so the story is
carrying you forward and the
journey is really
important and every time you
kind of move you open up a whole
new area
adjacent to your hub and once
you've captured an area so to
speak you can
fast travel in between them oh
is that what that flag okay that
makes sense
where are we here so this is the
first city that I mentioned
earlier okay which
is now totally in ruins yeah
this is a city I don't see a
city it was supposed
to be this was sort of like like
the place that the colonization
started
right that huge thing that we
saw on the horizon like
dominating the skyline so
that's the engine of the arc
ship that brought us here and
the whole idea of
the colonization plan was that
that was going to be our nuclear
energy source
that would power the city but
then the anomaly hit and that
being melted down
and it irradiated half the city
and you know those who could
escaped into rift
town and those who couldn't the
X Isles were trapped out here so
this is this is
now home base of the insurgents
that you're moving into you
moving into their
territory now and okay I guess
we're moving on here to the
Pyromancer this is
a lot of fire yeah all
is about the fire and
this place is filled with
enemies filled with really
dangerous monster what's
that yeah you're not fighting on
it with humanity remember what
we said in the
beginning that whatever anime
touches it changes yes not the
creature that
mutated from his four creatures
now they are not only no there
is no cute
creatures anymore here because
you are powerful you are almost
godlike we were
skills but the threat is even
more dangerous so have to fight
us really
really nasty creatures in your
journey man all right that's
gonna be fine
that's gonna be fun I'm not like
into shooting creatures unless
they're like
really scared so
listen this is right
I got a lot of the classic tees
of the gigantic boss battle at
the end yeah and
that kick-ass gun -
yeah yeah right right
and that gear right there is
badass is that's kind of the
gear that you get
toward the end of the game oh
yeah this is a game that is
about going on a
journey to solve an amazing
mystery and getting some really
kick-ass gear no
question about it the place you
start this game is so far from
where you end
up you go from playing as a
human to something way beyond
you you really you
leave humanity behind yeah leave
humanity behind that's kind of
how I
feel sometimes when I watcthe
news I'm like totally for that
cinnamon alright
guys and that about does it for
the outriders revealed stream
the world's
press and media they've already
played the game and right after
the stream they
are going to flood the internet
with the content of all their
playthrough so make
sure you check that out and guys
thank you so much for your time
sitting here
and chatting with me and I
cannot wait to play the game
pretty sure there's a
lot more you guys are going to
reveal between now and when the
game comes out
which is later this year so guys
if you want to know all the
updates that are
happening with this game make
sure you check out outriders
dotnet and with that
Gus thanks again for your
time man chat man thank you
you